[Music]
we are going to talk about how to make
sense of all of our compute pieces way
to run your stuff
give hopefully a good lay of the land of
where things are at I was talking with
folks ahead of time a bunch of data
science related folks in the room I'm
not going to talk about anything machine
learning or data science directly but
about the platforms that run a lot of
that stuff on our systems so might be
useful there so let's get going so the
key question where should I run my code
and unfortunately the answer is it
depends
thus we have a whole talk about it so
let's get into it at a really high level
I'm going to talk about five different
products and I was talking with folks I
think half the challenge and getting
started in Google Cloud is actually just
so many names of all of the things
there's like a couple hundred names you
need to learn just to kind of make sense
of all the parts so these are the names
we're going to talk about today and
starting the top we have cloud functions
which is functions as a service app
engine which is for taking a set of code
and running that as a website usually
cloud run which is new and we'll talk
about that in details like announced
today kubernetes engine which is a
hosted kubernetes cluster and compute
engine which are virtual machines
Network and disk running there so just
out of curiosity how many people heard
of containers sorry thank you for
raising your hands and server Louis and
everybody has a different definition we
have 100 people here we probably have a
hundred definitions of server lists is
my guess so my operating general
definition here is mostly around the
kind of operational model of you pay for
the actual usage you get the
infrastructure itself is managed you
focus on your code that sort of thing
there's another angle as well though
that I
think is interesting and we usually like
take these like directly together and
there are cases where we can tease these
apart a little bit and is the
programming model itself like what it
looks like from a developer standpoint
and most things that our server lists
are not actually storing state between
function calls right you have side
effects of your code or return values of
the functions usually kind of a hosted
service event-driven as a word I'm going
to talk about a bit more but usually is
something that causes it to happen
request comes in or an event fires and
we're trying to make these more and more
open so that you could run them in lots
of places and I'll talk about that a bit
okay so the key question here is like
there's so many choices am I going to
make the right decision like like kind
of decision paralysis sort of thing and
and I get there and my goal for the talk
is really two things we kind of like get
a a big map of the territory about what
these pieces are and like relax a little
bit about the the risk here like I'm
gonna try to make the case that it's
fairly easy to move around after you've
made a starting decision so no worries
and at a really high level and this is
the kind of able to move up and down the
top - you're mostly focusing as a
developer on the code you write the
actual function signature what returns
from it or the URL maps to different
parts of the code that sort of thing and
down here we're mostly focused on
building a runtime environment with the
right binaries the the files it needs
the container of the of the code itself
and then a compute engine we're looking
at a whole operating system they're
virtual machines you can install
anything you want on them
that sort of deal so I'm just gonna go
all the way through all of them and move
kind of quick and then circle back
around
so cloud functions
when you're using cloud functions you
are writing just one function and it
maps usually to a URL but some kind of
event that comes in and as a developer
you just think about what inputs what
side-effects and what outputs and that's
the whole world while you're thinking
about that function the events can come
from a lot of different places it's very
common for them to come in as an HTTP
request but in cloud more words pub/sub
is our messaging bus cloud storage is an
object store and then there's a few
other options as well like hooks to
firebase and the like and these are
fully managed you just write the code
hit deploy and it scales up and down and
you pay for exactly what you actually
use nothing more nothing less
and it Auto scales with actual usage so
the idea is hopefully you can just
concentrate on that one part of the
world and not worry about anything else
so when you're using these you were
thinking about the like doing system
design you're thinking about what events
are going to cause the function to
execute and what it does so that's the
the mental space you're in when you're
working with functions and I mean it's
the classic definition of serverless in
a way so it's a good fit for things that
are serviced when you're making
integrations between other pieces events
are coming from pub/sub or storage like
you can set things up so you send a new
object to a cloud storage bucket and
that causes a function to fire that does
something to it maybe makes a different
version of it copies it somewhere else
that sort of thing and it's used
sometimes in ETL processes or
transactional things where you need to
like for example the storage example
every time a new item goes in you do
something to it and then my favorite
kind of mental model is just thinking of
these are these are the glue of the web
you know this is the the HTTP glue that
connects everything together on the
constraints side you are thinking seeing
the entire world through this function
granularity and so as you build more
complicated systems
you pieced together more functions to do
that and that works pretty well and then
at a certain point it might be hard to
reason about or it might be more
challenging to monitor or troubleshoot
and so pay attention to that and in
cloud functions there are only specific
runtimes available so if you're writing
in those languages awesome if you're not
you might not find them as useful so
what does this look like let's see look
at cloud functions actually let me just
go to the top a little bit this is the
Google cloud platform web UI looking at
a specific project and in my opinion
this is the single most important thing
the hamburger button because it gets to
all the other pieces if you don't find
that it's really hard to do anything but
if we come in and look at functions I've
got several functions set up and let's
go ahead and use node because I think a
lot of folks are using node JavaScript
based functions and this one's already
built so it's got some source code and
all its really doing is saying for every
request that comes in let's look for
some stuff in the message body or in the
request or in the body and if I don't
find that just use hello world and
return that back out the function so
this is kind of hello world of of
functions and it automatically gets a
URL and you can map additional ones but
if we if we run this we get the default
input okay but I wanted to do something
different so there's this testing window
over here so we can actually kind of
simulate giving it a body in a post
request as part of the post and so we go
message
and hello lovely next peoples that's you
and we run the function and we get a
different output so yeah a proof that
it's real additionally we can view the
logs because the actual execution logs
and any log messages you emit during the
function call go to stackdriver logging
so you can see them all in a central
place and the like so it's a very very
quick taste of what that can feel like
and of course you can also do that
through the command line or via api's as
well just kind of a web interface to it
so why would you pick cloud functions so
a big part is you don't to think about
the infrastructure or the servers at all
like classic serverless and this
granularity of payment so if you have
things that are very spiky or you you
don't run very often they will be
extremely afford like less inexpensive
I'm trying to avoid saying cheap they'll
be very inexpensive all the way you know
if you're not running the very often and
then can scale up to lots of load right
and it's a very straightforward
developer experience you've got your
code and it runs okay deep breath
and now a pension so App Engine takes
the code focus but goes out of a level
to think about a whole application so
we're talking about Oh
usually a web application access the
sweet spot for App Engine and so you'll
have your url mappings of this URL calls
this code this URL calls that code maybe
there's some shared code there's a whole
kind of structure of the application
that's all one piece so that's kind of
the way you see the world when using App
Engine again no service to manage it
scales up and down really fast but it
has some additional features like
versioning of the the codebase and then
you can do traffic splitting across
those versions so as you do a new
release you can say oh I'd like to give
a small amount of traffic to the new
release and then hoops roll that back
that sort of thing if it doesn't work
out App Engine has been s port like it's
existed longer than Google cloud itself
has actually it predates GCP so we have
it actually has three different
execution environments there's a classic
kind of standard edition and there's our
newer second-gen runtimes and
additionally you can actually use the
same view of the world and have the code
deployed to VMs and that's called the
flexible environment so there are some
differences between these environments
if you're starting new projects I highly
recommend go straight for the second gen
pieces if you need to for example if you
need to listen on ports to do WebSockets
or something other than HTTP like what
you need other than short HTTP you can
do that on the VMS if you need certain
machine sizes like you need a really
particular big machine size you might go
to flex but by and large people are
running in the second gen standard
nowadays and in this space the runtimes
are actually open-source they are
written to be idiomatic they should feel
like the programming language you're
using so I should feel like Python to
Python people and feel like node to node
people we have the set of supported
wrote in x there will be a talk at this
event talking about a new alpha for our
Ruby runtime for Ruby folks out there
and you you basically call GCP api's
directly whereas in the the original app
engine standard runtime which predated
the rest of cloud there were a lot of
kind of built-in API is for things like
memcache and and other things so when
you're using App Engine you are
primarily thinking about your code base
the HTTP requests that come in like what
URLs and where they map that sort of
thing and different versions of your app
kind of for going forward and back in
fact you can actually even break the app
up into modules if you need to but
that's the primary mental model you're
in when you're using App Engine so it's
a great fit it's natural like sweet spot
is HTTP web like request response
applications like there's a there's an
execution timeout so you can't do really
long-running things but it's meant for
these kind of like back-and-forth
requests things it scales very well both
down to run to like zero instances of
your backends running all the way to
very high so a lot of folks are using it
in like advertising for example where
you have almost no traffic until I can
add thing runs and then it goes really
really big and then it drops back off or
maybe like kind of long tails out for a
while but you need to leave it up I'm
only paying for what you're using again
there are only certain runtimes
available so you know if you're running
in those languages you're gonna be
happier it might not be able use it if
not and it is the the window to the
world is the web that's how it sees
everything is is through HTTP
and on the flexible side it can run
anything that fits in a container but
it's running on VMs and they don't scale
quite as quickly so we need to leave a
few runnings so it doesn't scale to zero
and it takes a little longer to respond
to new traffic coming in by the longer I
mean like like minute ish couple minutes
kind of territory rather than seconds or
sub second kind of timeframe so you
might choose App Engine because it lets
you just focus on your code maybe your
your organization is primarily
developers that's what you care about or
maybe for this particular app you don't
want to invest the opps into it because
it's not your core thing so the part of
your system it's very much optimized for
web focused workloads and it's
especially good for things that vary a
lot over time and this stat is probably
like out of date but I couldn't find the
newest one definitely lots and lots and
lots of traffic on App Engine as a whole
and we can handle the load that you've
got there is the the point to make there
okay so now actually we've got a new
thing and there is a talk later today
that goes into the details of this this
is cloud run and what we're trying to do
if you look around the internet there's
a lot of like serverless versus
containers kind of conversations like
which one do you do like they're like
they're in a duel to the like end of
time or something and we're trying to
bring these together more like you know
like peanut butter and jelly or you know
some best buddies or something like that
right so we're trying to give serverless
kind of agility that pay for what you
use to scale up and scale down to nearly
anything you can put in a container that
listens on HTTP so what it is you give
it a URL to an image
that has some code in it that will
listen to HTTP on whatever the port
environment variable is and in return
you get something that like scales up
and down very quickly you get the SSL
termination the HTTP request binding
through all the load balancers and the
like and really nice thing for
efficiency is that it's not just single
threaded you can actually if you're
running Java or you're running you go or
something that has really good
concurrency you can actually handle
multiple requests from the same binary
execution and so if if you're writing
something that actually has to wait on
other Network calls you can actually
make get a lot of efficiency there and
what you're paying for and scales up and
down really fast and you're paying very
very precisely for the CPU in memory
you're using down to like 100
millisecond granularity that's the
hosted fully managed version with the
same developer experience there's also a
back-end that runs on top of kubernetes
and so you can you can deploy things in
the same way have all the load balancing
and everything set up correctly the
service end points and everything hooked
up but it's part of a kubernetes cluster
you already have or that you're trying
to build out on your on your systems it
deeply integrates with the policy and
control you're already running there if
you need custom hardware you need
specific kinds of accelerators like GPUs
or TP use available you can do that and
because it's running on top of
kubernetes we can actually run this in a
lot of places so essentially we're
trying to if you're coming from the
server less angle of you know not
thinking about backends and you want to
just have more options think about the
the fully managed cloud run if you're
coming at this from I want to offer
server lists to the people who are using
server list experience to the people who
are using my kubernetes cluster then the
running on top of cloud run angle our on
top of gke angle makes a lot of sense
for cloud running so same developer
experience two different backends you
can move between them just by
redeploying the same app so you
and start one place and just redeploy to
the other and go okay so let's let's try
to make this real this is the the hello
world app so we're not gonna go to real
but it is real
so we're basically sorry let's start at
the beginning
back at our project top choose cloud run
and then we'll go straight to create
service it includes a handy little URL
to an image that's known to work so I'll
go ahead and paste that in I'm just
gonna call it hello US central one and
here's where you can set some more
information about how much memory you're
gonna give to it and how many requests
you'd like each instance of the software
to handle so if you've got a single
threaded app you can set that to one if
you can handle more things at the same
time you can set it higher so we go
ahead and hit create this is doing a
bunch of stuff in the background
actually deploying the containers
configuring load balancers like making
sure we've got SSL and all stuff set up
this is going to be the URL to our app
if we click on it it doesn't work right
now so yeah it's it's actually real life
and something that might be a little bit
surprising is if I put my cursor in the
lower right hand corner of the screen
turns off that was probably not expected
the yamo like under the covers there is
a yam will file to describe this and it
is based if you've done a lot of
kubernetes stuff you might have seen
these configuration files before in yeah
mol format and this file you can take
this and run it in other environments so
you don't have to care about it but you
can take this full configuration and run
in other places which is pretty fun okay
and it says green check box so let's try
to refresh this
forbidden what'd I do wrong let's
refresh all the things is this the
chrome thing where you need to like
control refresh demo fail
Oh see I'm not authenticated thank you
mover the audience I didn't check the
box for actually authenticating this
that's not gonna work very well is it
for for leaving it wide open I did that
wrong let's deploy any revision and now
we'll go all the way back and just make
a new a new one this is a speaker being
stubborn
after making mistake this is the box
that I should have checked thank you and
we will grab this URL
give it a new name that is awesome
and hit create okay so while that's
going I'm gonna give you a sneak on the
next little bit so when you're using
cloud run you're thinking about building
the container environment
for the processes you have so you can
run any language you like it doesn't
anything that will run on Linux in a
docker container you can run that
understands how to do HTTP so you listen
you look for the environment variable
port you open a listening socket on that
port and you're good to go
it is however stateless in that there's
a local filesystem but that's actually
in memory and so between invitations of
your app it just goes away so you can't
store a lot of stuff locally and you
shouldn't other than maybe cache if you
have to it's mostly there for
compatibility with libraries that expect
it so you should think everything that
comes in and goes out let's try to go
back and see if we got got a new URL now
deployed just now moment of truth it's
running yay thank you thank you
members of the audience and supporting
me and it's really a live demo thing
okay so this is a good fit for things
that are stateless again HTTP
request/response workloads that's how
you talk to it is through the load
balancers over HTTP it can handle bursty
traffic it scales down all the way to
zero you pay for exactly what you use
and if you have a scenario where you
really need specific runtimes or
languages or binaries around there it's
not just the code you're actually
writing you could include other things
that you shell out too or whatever you
need to do in that docker image to solve
problems if you've got some really
gnarly stuff that's been around the
office forever like if you can put in a
container you can put that on the web
make it feel serverless the constraint
side it is again containers so it has to
be in a container to run it
and because we're getting a little more
focused here how you build those images
is up to you
so it depends well you have to decide
now you're gonna do it we have cloud
build there's lots of other CI CD tools
out there anything that results in a
docker image in a repository that has
the other things like lessons out of
port and stuff you can use in here so
why would you use it if you want this
developer experience it's kind of
service developer experience you have
the option of having it be fully managed
or deeply integrated with kubernetes and
you can decide later at offer at ops
time even a different group of people
what that deployment environment
actually looks like so you can do all of
your dev work in one and then decide
later to switch to the other just by
deploying the code and you can run
basically anything it runs in a
container over HTTP and then I got a new
word that shows up here at the end I'm
claiming open and Kay native kubernetes
so you can actually run these same
images on Kay native on top of
kubernetes anywhere that kubernetes runs
so if you want to run this on your own
machines you've got your own data center
you're in another cloud you want to run
it in all the places you can take this
same runtime environment and run it in
all of those and make that decision at
deployment time as well so there's cloud
run hopefully you think it's awesome
give it a try the the place we're at
right now is we're just releasing it so
we want everybody to try it out see what
they're what what appeals to them most
maybe it's something we didn't think of
and let us know how that works
what did you try to do and how did it
turn out so I will have my contact info
at the end I would love to hear from you
did it work like does it work for you
for the problems did something come to
mind as I was describing it and and if
you try that does it work
okay next level down google kubernetes
engine which is just managed kubernetes
so the thing I've been doing though is
I've said kubernetes a lot here but I
never said what it is and I won't make
you raise your hands but I'm sure
somebody's like WTF kubernetes sorry
so kubernetes is a management system for
running lots of containers so containers
give you this isolation for a process it
sees the same files every time it turns
on every time you start one up they see
the same exact state so try to solve
that like well it worked on my machine
but it doesn't work over here problem
and if you and if you want to do a lot
of those you end up want to do that on
lots of machines and that's what
kubernetes is for it lets you talk to a
whole cluster as if it's kind of one one
big machine so you can say okay
kubernetes I want to run a thousand of
those and it'll figure out where to run
them that sort of thing and then a whole
bunch of features for making that
relatively easy to manage reliable
sensible troubleshooting all the fun
stuff and I'll make the claim I think
it's become like what an in fact a way
of doing that running containers on lots
of machines so kubernetes engine is
hosted and managed kubernetes on google
cloud so we run the master node for you
we keep the compute nodes up-to-date
basically kind of moving things off of
them and rebooting creating new ones if
they need sorority patches or what have
you do the software updates for
kubernetes itself and the underlying OS
and then do integration with things like
the load balancer and do cluster auto
scaling to manage and follow you the
load that you have so basically makes it
easier to operate a kubernetes cluster
and if you're at all if you're starting
with kubernetes are interested in
getting started with kubernetes in my
opinion no matter where you plan on
running it this is a really great place
to start because you can just in about
five minutes have a cluster up and going
and you're good you can experiment with
it see if the model works for what
you're trying to do and go from there
so when you're using kubernetes you're
definitely thinking at a different level
of abstraction we talked about so far
you're thinking about how different
parts of your software talk to other
parts of your your system so you might
have five instances of like a web
front-end and one database and a couple
of cache servers or something like that
so it starts to feel a little bit more
like a UML diagram or a diagram you
might draw on a whiteboard with your
colleagues and then we express them as
these EML files but you can get you can
actually take these that are computer
oriented descriptions of that whiteboard
thing and push them in a cluster and
have it actually create that structure
which is really powerful and you're
thinking about the application as a
whole and hopefully not thinking much
about how many computers do I have how
do they talk to each other because
kubernetes manages how the things find
each other how they where the processes
actually run and that sort of thing
so keeps you thinking about the logical
connections between your app and
insulates you in many ways from the
actual execution environment so you can
run it in different clouds or on your
own machines so that's the key thing in
my mind it's a really good fit for
scenarios where you need to run in
multiple environments so you need to
have the same thing run on a dev cluster
that's on your own machines but you're
going to deploy it to a cloud or to
clouds or you need to be make sure you
have the same environment for dev tests
and prod but it you can't have all the
same number of machines that sort of
thing if you really want to take full
advantage of containers go all-in
there's just a lot more configurability
available in kubernetes
it does make the most sense when you
have really good communications with the
other teams in your organization because
you're going to need to have
conversations about how things get built
how security patches are going to work
that the ops folks the devs folks agree
on approach and some conventions in
places probably that they can all commit
to the same repos to make changes if
they need to and you're probably going
to want some sort of build pipeline
system to do that collaboration in and
it does give you like you are have
processes listening on ports that can
talk to each other via load balancing
routing so if you need to do anything
everything I've talked about so far has
all been like HTTP HPS right so you want
to other stuff like there's lots of lots
of options for connecting the pieces
here still you must be in containers
there's some can be some challenges
around licensing we're like licenses for
some apps are actually per machine so
you have to do some pinning or some
special things with labels in order to
make sure that the processes always end
up on those on those machines that
you've got the licenses set up for and
you know Cabernets has an opinion about
how things talk to each other and so
that can influence the architecture you
decide to do so kubernetes can raise
engine you know can insulate you from a
lot of infrastructure the reason
Google's excited about a lot of this
stuff is it enables high utilization
which saves money you can run the same
stuff reliably at higher utilization and
not leave a bunch of open Headroom for
every app individually because you've
got a reliable cluster you can move the
processes around on so you can actually
safely and reliably run much higher
utilization which directly equals save
money the abstractions that it provides
are a real sweet spot for a lot of folks
and you are gonna have to kind of figure
out what you're gonna do for logging and
monitoring and how all the pieces put
together so there's that
okay next level down virtual machines so
now we're we're like in the territory of
like we've got an operating system of
some kind and everything above that is
up to you all of it including like OS
patches and the like which means you can
stall whatever kernel you want and like
additional things you may need to do
there like if you've got scenarios where
you need that you can do that on these
VMs one thing I want to highlight is we
often talk about scaling out in cloud
right you know or lots of little
processes and the like this is an area
like they're getting quite large we just
last week announced machines with up to
12 terabytes of RAM and like I would to
another companies retail site and looked
for big hard disks that I could order
yesterday and the largest I could find
was 14 terabytes so if you want to go
order a hard disk it's 14 terabytes
pretty soon you're gonna be able to like
just a virtually turn on a machine that
has 12 terabytes of memory and so like
probably the like so yes there's limits
on how far you can scale up but they're
probably higher than we are thinking
right so yeah they start very quickly
usually around 20 seconds we have a
bunch of pre-built OS images that are
managed in the sense of we make sure
that they've got stuff installed on them
that makes it easy to use Google Cloud
you can get the the on OS update systems
kind of go through repo mirrors that we
have and so as security patches happen
it all happens fairly locally so
consider those you can but you can also
you know you can actually make a block
device that is bootable and upload that
and boot off of it right so you can do
all the way down to running whatever you
want on these on these machines I want
to highlight like these are virtual
machines they're like CPU network disk
and the like but a lot of the pieces are
not so intuitive so the disks are most
like the persistent disk which is our
default disk is a network attached
storage which so the block device is
actually spread out on like thousands of
machines so and they actually compete to
return the data back so the the random
read that you expect from spinning disk
even though it's spinning disk it's
actually lots of them
so you get a really flat latency instead
of a spiky latency on reads and it's
it's faster than you would think and
because these pages are all spread out
all over the place
you can actually take a snapshot of the
disk while it's connected with almost no
interruption on the machine there's just
a little blip where you need to have a
lock for a couple milliseconds to say
this is the most recent block that's
there and then behind the scenes it can
actually copy that all off and make a
snapshot of the full disk that you can
then restore to make another computer
with exactly that data on it and you can
do that anywhere in any of the zones we
have so you can take a snapshot in the
US and restore it in Asia or Europe or
wherever and do that and I mentioned
somebody earlier that leads to some
non-intuitive effects that larger discs
are faster and which wait what so bigger
discs are actually faster so if you're
doing tests of speed on these VMs look
at the docks and look at the trade-offs
because you need to make sure your disk
is fast enough for the IUP's you want
and the reason for that is that discs
come like with a combined like amount of
i/o and storage on them and put those
note on the data center and we want to
be fair to people who are trying to get
all the IEEE ops possible and other
folks are trying to store like big piles
of data so the two are actually linked
up so if you want the fastest throughput
on the disks you need larger disks and
vice versa I guess you want lots of
storage you need larger just to so pay
attention to that when you go to
performance testing and the other piece
these machines come and go really
quickly right 20 seconds but like you
don't need kubernetes to get auto
scaling like you can actually make
what's called a managed instance group
of identical like that you make a VM
template and then it will scale up and
down multiple machines load balanced
across them and like do that based on
the traffic you have or a value you can
set in the API so you can actually scale
up a cluster and down very easily if
you're trying to build like a disaster
recovery site don't leave all of them
running all the time like have a managed
instance group of the front ends running
it like one really small one and then
when the disaster actually happens then
spin up all the machines you save so
much money like the it's it's really
easy to think of these as a one-to-one
equivalents and I want to encourage you
to think of them as being very elastic
like and that's true for the individual
machines as though you are these groups
of machines but I rates right you can
actually mix and match and have like a
lot of memory and very little CPU or the
opposite and you can start with a
machine that's very very small stop it
change the settings and reboot it to
have you know 160 V CPUs right so it
starts with two when you're like okay
just reboot now I've got 100 so it's
very very elastic take advantage of that
so when you're using virtual machines
using compute engine you're thinking
about your software what's running on
the machine you're thinking about the
operating system itself the disk images
a CPU Ram disk ratios the networking how
they talk to each other there's a lot
more moving pieces but you have control
over all of them where you know there's
cases where you really want to need that
so it's all there so it's a really
really really good fit for existing
systems so it's almost always the right
first step for a system that already
exists and you're trying to get some
advantages of cloud from it
like this is almost always the place to
start you'll get a lot of benefits just
moving the machines over things like
these snapshots to take backups and the
like the networking there is the
possibility of I just want to all that
want to do is run a container I just got
this one image I just want to run it
once there as you're starting a VM you
can actually click and say I want to run
this container and we'll start a
container optimized OS and start that
one container and just do the one if you
have needs for a specific kernel or OS
version particularly license
requirements probably if you're trying
to run a database you're going to be
happier here it's possible to do in some
of the other things but there's a lot
more moving parts and then again if
you've got network protocols beyond HTTP
HTTP the scaling is more granular it's
still pretty quick in the big terms but
you know takes 20-30 seconds to start up
a VM you can start lots of them in a
minute or two but there's a granularity
there if you're trying to do really
spiky workloads it might not keep up and
you want to look higher okay I'm gonna
skip the most of the demo but I can't
resist nope
there we go and basically the way this
looks is you pick a name you choose the
kind of balance of kind of pre preset
number of CPUs versus memory or click
customize and you get these sliders and
you're like oh I want this shape machine
and I pick a different disk and that
sort of thing so I'm not gonna actually
do this in log in because I'm trying to
say too many things in one thing but I
wanted to highlight down here at the
bottom and this is true for a lot of the
UI there's this little thing that says
oh what's the equivalent rest or command
line and this will give you the actual
JSON that the web app is going to send
to the API to do what you do when you
click or the g-cloud command to do the
same thing so if you explore a flow that
you like and you want to automate that
you can actually copy this out put it in
a script put it on a scheduled task and
go so it's a really powerful way to kind
of learn your way around okay so why
compute engine you want consistency you
should be able to get the same the same
behavior I stopped it so we laughed hey
you same behavior in tests and then
later in prod you get these very custom
VMs you can actually I didn't even fit
because these disks or block devices are
our virtual block devices you can
actually make them larger while the
machines running so anyway we run out of
disk before and had a machine go down
you can actually make the disk bigger
while it's on it's really powerful we
have a lot of things we've done in
billing to try to make it really easy to
understand so it's basically build in
small increments like seconds
and if you just leave it on we
automatically give you discounts so
there's up to like a 30% discount if it
runs for a whole month and by it I mean
number of CPUs and I'm out of memory on
the same kind of general machine shape
not that specific machine so you can
restart them and that sort of thing
and pay their and we have this thing
called preemptable machines that are our
attempt to get you to think really
flexibly because they're up to 80%
discount of the price of a regular vm
they're the same VMS but they could be
stopped within 30 to 60 seconds at any
time and they will not live more than 24
hours so it encourages you to think
about writing your your tools in terms
of like jobs that come in do some work
move on that sort of thing and if you do
you can just immediately say like a
quarter to a fifth of the overall price
just boom like it goes down to that so
it's 80% off like 70 to 80% off look at
preemptable machines it's totally worth
it
but it will turn off so make your stuff
so that it reboots and works off queues
and things and we use compute engine to
build a lot of our own services so a lot
of folks here we're talking about data
so data flow and data proc are actually
built on top of computers and instances
the managed sequel services we have
actually run on top of compute engine
instances these are very powerful and
really strong building blocks for your
systems as well so part me ok I promise
to answer this question right we've
mostly just talked about a bunch of
things
so we're back to here hopefully these
make more sense than they did a little
while ago
if in hearing this you're like oh that's
it great
start there but probably we're still and
it depends a little bit so here's some
additional thoughts to think about that
may push you up or down in between these
abstractions so you may have a different
abstraction of what you want to work at
there may be some technical requirements
you have or some things about your team
the people you work with that might like
make you want to choose one or the other
so thinking in terms of abstractions
this is just summarizing kind of what I
said there you're thinking about events
and functions or just your codebase or
the container format or the UML diagram
of the app right or the actual like
representation of a machine so like what
abstraction do you want to be working at
and it might be different for different
problems you may have technical
requirements that are gonna push you one
way or the other
and in this case usually down like the
stack so you know you're usually going
to going to need to like go below give
an abstraction levels so if you need
like direct control over URL routing you
want to share code more easily have more
control of versions and traffic
splitting that'll bring you from
functions to App Engine
if you need very specific programming
languages or environments the like
that's gonna bring you more towards
setting up the container to run in cloud
one you need a specific things from your
OS you're doing hybrid work network
protocols beyond HP that'll bring you
probably to Cooper Nettie's and then you
want to just basically own the whole
thing that'll bring you to VMs there's
also billing model differences between
these so like how you plan for paying
for them and how it works so functions
App Engine and managed cloud run are
very granular pay for actual use of the
the CPU and memory network involved in
doing that that's
transaction cloud run on g ke g ke
itself so kubernetes and VMS you're
standing up a set of resources and
paying for them while they're on and
then you turn them off you stop paying
for them so there's a different model
for how you pay for it how you plan for
that payment and predict what it's going
to cost like how you do that so that may
affect your decisions the teams are
working on is it is it a group of all
devs working on a new thing that's going
to have you in a very different place
then like we're trying to keep this
stuff working and we have to write my
favorite definition of enterprise is
it's any environment where most of the
applications don't have an application
team working on them like you've got a
whole bunch of stuff that has to run but
you can't change them so like that's
gonna probably have you start work
towards the compute engine side of
things so some balance is there if
you're trying to kind of find a mapping
of other things I attempted to make a
map of like how you might do similar
things in other places right so
functions as a service there's lots of
like I think all the the clouds and lots
of open source environments have a way
to run functions I've struggled a bit to
find a clear equivalent for App Engine
maybe something like Cloud Foundry or
app scale which is an open source app
engine like environment cloud run is
basically the the UX is a little bit
different but the the execution
environment is K native an sto on
kubernetes so you can run that that same
stuff there you can move those workloads
very easily kubernetes is kubernetes so
like the the environment around it is
different like what you call but like
the same stuff should work wherever you
can run it there and then basically
there's lots and lots of options for
running whole OSS on virtual machines so
some of these are easier to do hybrid or
multi environment than others so back to
making the right decision and and kind
of no worries hopefully this feels a
little more comfortable
so you can definitely use them together
most real systems use multiples at once
it's not like an all-or-nothing kind of
thing we have tools that make this a lot
easier and better I won't go into
details so the photos here are probably
good but pub/sub allows you to send
messages between all the things storage
lets you store arbitrary blobs or emit
like data separate from all the things
cloud tasks are like a queue of things
that need doing and you want to make
sure that they all happen so
transactional queuing kind of things and
scheduler is cron in the cloud basically
so at this time run that and do that
every week kind of thing so those all
help you glue the pieces together and
you can move up and down these I'll be
honest it's easier to move down in terms
of human effort than it is to move up so
if you get things into containers that
gives you more options and you can move
back and forth more easily and we're
trying to make the environments as
similar as possible from all of these
environments you can hit a thing called
the metadata server and get tokens for
the scope of access rights you have
around Google Cloud so you can always
look to there to get your security token
for what you're allowed to do whatever
the environment is you can use
stackdriver from all of them
we've just today announced VPC access
you can have your App Engine and cloud
functions show up on the 10 network of
your VMs
and not like do the public internet loop
and we're working on that for cloud run
and here we are back here so my claim is
if you've got something that looks like
these that's probably the place to start
evaluating and then look at those
options so thank you all very very very
much
[Music]